each week wandavision reveals new and
more interesting layers to its strange
tv-inspired reality
episode v is certainly no exception with
plenty of hidden pop culture and mcu
references
here are a few easter eggs you likely
missed in episode five of wandavision
when we return to one division's strange
sitcom reality and on a very special
episode
wanda vision and all the residents of
west view have moved into the prime time
programming of the 80s
in particular the intro borrows from
family ties among other things family
ties is known for making the young
michael j fox famous even before he
became a time traveler in 1985's back to
the future
the most blatant pull from the series is
the initially colorless portrait that
begins to be colored in by a paintbrush
controlled by wanda
family ties intro for its first three
seasons included a similar portrait
it's a nifty visual allusion to the way
wanda colored in the gray and lifeless
vision that viewers briefly spotted at
the end of wandavision's fourth episode
on a very special episode has its share
of 80s references but they don't all
stay in the 80s
when agnes visits wanda and vision she
tells them she stopped by on her way to
jazzercise
founded in the late 60s and still around
today jazzercise hit its peak in the mid
80s
we get another purely 80s reference
toward the end of the episode
in the kitchen wanda tells vision well
life moves pretty fast out in the
suburbs
it sounds a lot like matthew broderick's
famous quote from 1986's ferris
bueller's day off
life moves pretty fast you don't stop
and look around once in a while
you could miss it but some of these
references don't really find homes in
the 80s
early in the episode agnes yells fussy
babies meet buns of steel
the buns of steel workout videos while
technically originating in the late 80s
didn't really become a craze until the
early 90s
we get a similar moment when norm
references a catchphrase that hit its
peak in the late 80s and 90s
what do you think norm should we surf
the internet cowabunga dude
cowabunga dude is most associated with
the teenage mutant ninja turtles and to
a lesser extent off-brand simpsons
merchandise
i have always liked
huh
these blurrings between 80s and 90s pop
culture could be intentional
it could be a sign that just as vision
is becoming more aware of wanda's
illusions the integrity of her dream
world is deteriorating
in the 2016 vision comic series vision
lives in the suburbs with a synthazoid
wife
son and daughter they also eventually
have a synthesis dog named sparky
not only is one division sparky a
callback to the comic series but his
close call with the kitchen's power
outlet is as well like the sparky of
wandavision the sparky of the comics
initially meets a sad
though much more brutal end however he's
eventually brought back to the land of
the living ironically considering
wanda's decision not to revive the pooch
and on a very special episode
scarlet witch is one of the heroes who
could bring the flying pooch back to
life
and on a very special episode
wandavision's strange advertisers are
back
this time the ad is for lagos a paper
towel brand showing lagos wiping up an
identical spill to what the leading
brand is trying and failing to clean
they add mirrors bounty commercials of
the 80s that touted their paper towels
the quicker picker-upper
the name lagos is a blatant reference to
captain america civil war
it's wanda who unintentionally incites
the film's conflict when she
accidentally kills wakandan volunteers
in the nigerian city of lagos
rather than calling lagos a quicker
picker-upper the ad ends with the slogan
lagos for when you make a mess you
didn't mean to
fittingly the juice that the towels
clean up resembles blood
one thing that's easy to miss about the
ad is the reference to what's going on
with vision
just before the end of the commercial
the husband knocks over a glass of beer
the wife hands him a few towels as the
narrator says husbands can use it too
you know
this could reflect not only how vision
begins to assert himself but how episode
5 shows he has a degree of control over
the illusions
for example he's able to temporarily
free norm from wanda's telepathy
this may also be why agnes is so
flustered early in the episode when she
isn't sure whether she's supposed to
hold the babies
because she's getting conflicting
signals from vision and wanda
and then of course there is the reveal
at the end of on a very special episode
that will doubtless go down as one of
the biggest tv moments of 2021.
the doorbell rings as wanda and vision
argue and after wanda answers the door
we're greeted by a familiar face
but familiar in a way that we don't
expect before we see the visitor's face
we see the back of his head which sports
a head of hair that looks a lot like the
one belonging to pietro maximon
wanda's brother who dies heroically in
avengers age of ultron
we are indeed greeted by wanda's brother
but a different pietro than the one most
viewers had to have been expecting
instead of aaron taylor johnson who
plays pietro in the mcu film
wanda finds herself facing evan peters
who plays peter maximoff in 2014's x-men
days of future past as well as the final
two films of fox's x-men franchise
not only does this have potentially huge
consequences for the fabric of the mcu
and not only is it an instant classic
fourth wall breaking moment but it's an
absolutely perfect homage to the sitcom
as darcy points out as she notices the
change pietro maximoff has been recast
alluding to the fact that american
sitcoms are famous for their sometimes
abrupt recasting of characters
one of the most well remembered examples
of this comes from a sitcom one division
mirrors in its second episode
bewitched the main character's husband
darren was recast when dick york was
replaced by dick sargent in the series 6
season
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite wand division moments are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one